мати
так, я можу говорити за наше
стати командним стилем спілкування
навчені з нами нашими
поведінка в ньому також частково через
психологічний персонал і буде в
рамки цього прогресу та навчання для нього
переконався, що ви нарешті отримаєте решту
також знижує рівень стресу
має певну дистанцію до людей
щоб ви просто спробували один
зберігати холодну голову і той
не відрізняються від цього загального
неспокійна атмосфера заразна
[Музика]
основна вимога понад усе
спочатку нейтралітет берлінців
поліція на кожному заході
ми взагалі не маємо на це права
будь-яка асоціація повинна щодо
вмісту з огляду на процеси
оцінити або прокоментувати
це головний пріоритет
нейтралітет
[Музика]
це теж моя робота, наприклад
прямий контакт anja
лінія розмежування між силами
як ви бачите тут також частково
також ходити з шоломом на боці
мати естафету на цьому
зробити лінію тренду прозорою
чому ми витримуємо те, що наше завдання
[Оплески]